I actually like what you said there
because
if the woman doesn't have the strong
masculine figure in her life that can
guide her in this direction
right then that's when she kind of needs
to take it upon herself
for that brief period of time to really
just exercise her masculine ability and
like take her emotions out of the
equation because listen emotions are
great but
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first album I agree
with the fact that the whole thing you
said about friends where it's like if
they're affecting you more than you're
affecting them then you should probably
get some new friends you want to be
investing you know stocks shares bonds
you want to be investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is Haram at least
the paper money is hot on provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic Hamza Andreas we will go in with
our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little Clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin so you
don't want to be on YouTube or the
internet or anything that that amount of
time but it's it's the the fact is
that's what we're doing
is
identity
is
[Music]
the three Muslims of North America
foreign foreign
you're doing well
thank you for having us
for being here with us
so tell us how does it feel when the
tables turn
yeah true
all right let's start with a short
introduction of yourselves and then we
can discuss our questions all right
so who wants to start first
I think Rami should go first yeah I
should go first all right
so me personally my name is
on Instagram and Tick Tock and
everywhere uh I've been studying Islam
for the past five six years uh but I've
been studying it traditionally properly
for the past two years I'm the lab with
I3 Institute uh I've been trying to give
a dawah and call people to Islam and
more so educate people about Islam and
and the differences between religions or
or you know a lack thereof uh and
Instagram and basically teaching what
Islam is the only way
um again Tick Tock candle
and this is basically my passion
inshallah
I'll go next time bro
so my name is fired I am 20. you know
what bro nowadays lately when people ask
me how old I am I always forget because
I'm getting so old now subhanallah I
feel like a grandpa so when people ask
me I don't even know but I was born in
97 so I'm 24. okay I grew up in Toronto
in uh Canada I'm originally from
Bangladesh I was born there came here
when I was four and currently I'm a
medical student I run the three Muslim
Channel with these two brothers and yeah
alhamdulillah algorithm Allah so we've
uh we've been able to have the honor and
the privilege to do some amazing work
for the last uh 10 months with the
channel and inshallah continues and it's
only up from here
foreign
so you just want me to say my name and
you know what I do that's pretty much it
right
yes all right inshallah
my name is Angel
I am 27 years old
and aside from running the podcast with
the two lovely Brothers here
I do my own little coaching thing it's
mainly like men's coaching
uh
and this this the the cookie cutter
version the the short
there's a there's a word for it but it's
a short version for sure
I think people are wondering what your
marriage status is as well
let's let's not talk about that yeah
brothers so let's start with the first
question
how did you come to Islam
um that's a good one so I'll answer this
one first yeah yeah
the way that I came to Islam is I
started doing this thing known as a uh
dopamine detox
and then a dopamine detox it's it's kind
of like what you do in Ramadan where you
strip everything away
um for the most part like it's not not
many people strip everything away from
what I'm seeing but I did that and I
remember I felt this pool to read the
Quran and I kind of kept putting it off
putting it off
and I was like you know what let me just
read it it's a book nonetheless it's not
gonna give me too much dopamine per se
and I remember every time I read it I
was self-reflect and meditate afterwards
on what I had just read and I Remember
by the third day of reading it the third
day voila is like everything clicked
when I was reflecting and I felt these
waves like rushing through my body and
at that moment I was like yo like I'm
Muslim I must be Muslim because I'm
feeling in some type of way and I
remember I hit up a fire and I was like
bro like I think I'm a Muslim now
and then he was uh he's the one that
basically gave me the whole crash course
on Islam and he gave me my shahada so
that is my story alhamdulillah
what a beautiful story
beautiful
I was an accident
because we got to save the best for Less
you know
so me personally Bismillah I uh I'm a
born Muslim but what really led me to
Islam was
trying everything that Islam told me not
to do and this is not me trying to say
you know I did this this and this no my
point is I live with the typical Western
you know post-modern life as a
university student and realized that
everything they said were supposed to do
and brings us happiness actually didn't
and I realized like it's just empty it
just leads me into a dark tunnel and
it's very difficult to get yourself out
of there because the biggest issue for
me was and I see this with everyone else
too you don't realize you're in the dark
tunnel yourself so when I finally
realized I was lost
I did what uh everyone that comes to
Islam uh sincerely does I just cried out
to Allah and at that point I didn't know
if I fully believed in Islam or I fully
I was kinda on the fence but I said you
know Allah if you're listening to me if
you can hear me please just help me I'm
lost and I'll do anything and if you can
help me I'm never gonna go back to uh
you know my old ways
and instantly I felt this Rush of Iman
in my heart that I know Anna felt
something similar
and it was these waves and as soon as I
thought that I realized okay
um I have two options now one
I could do what a lot of people might do
which is realize that okay Allah helped
me but okay now I'm good now now I can
go back to you know doing what I was
doing or two okay no Allah help me and
as a not just a man but as a Muslim I
should have integrity and I should honor
what Allah has done for me because Allah
doesn't owe me any favors all right
let's get that clear so I realized okay
since that day I can't turn back and I
haven't turned back ever since and every
day I realized it's just a step forward
every day and that's all that matters
inshallah
I don't know I mean
mashallah
I I wouldn't consider my story the best
at Allah you know it is it is really
generic but uh so
I was born into a Muslim family right
and my parents they charged with me they
taught me um you know so does the fatty
I had to pray all the basics and um
Tahiti the prophet sallam uh but they
weren't they didn't mean much to me they
were just words names and all that
um
alhamdulillah they taught me good morals
and everything Islamic morals and
everything but growing up you know
growing up in the west it's just it's a
different it's a different ball game you
get out there and then you you learn
everything
opposite test to them uh so basically I
was living that kind of Lifestyle as
like you know regular high school kid
until
I was like 16 years old uh and it's kind
of lie I don't know what it is I don't
know what happened but basically I was I
was going to a Catholic school so I was
being taught to their you know their
Catholic beliefs and the religion uh
classes and everything and um I
distinctly remember one in grade 11
actually I believe in the first semester
when I was 16. or maybe even 15. the the
teacher knew I was a Muslim so every
time he would teach something about slam
because it's a world religions class now
he would um he would look at me and I'm
like
but I I didn't know like I'd nod my head
like yeah yeah that's right but I didn't
know anything
um and then that really struck me he's
found a lot and when I got home uh one
day after school I was going through my
phone on YouTube and I just saw a video
that was like at least and how he became
shaytan in the story of Satan and I'm
like this is interesting so I click on
it
and then he starts telling the story of
Elise and how he's uh he's from the Jinn
he's not a fallen angel angels Don't
disobey Allah and so on and so forth
he's quoting quranic ayat that are
talking about you know perhaps there are
other existences other than us and and
all this and to this day it's kind of
law I can't find the video I've been
trying to find it I can't find it
but something happened after watching
that video I was just like this has to
be the truth like this has to be the
truth the way he was speaking and
everything was so eloquent he was so
sure of what he was saying and and the
message itself was so beautiful and
precise and clear and I'm like this is
the religion I was born on to that I
drifted away that I allowed myself to
drift away from and then ever since then
I just every single day just straight
like lectures and like just lecture
after lecture after lecture quranic uh
Surah after Surah after Surah and then
now I'm here alhamdulillah
you can probably
think of that the views can resonate
with all of your stories because
I don't know if you know the saying but
just a quick input that
the shaytan never goes into an empty
house or like the thief goes never into
an empty house so Allah has put
something into into you and so all these
iblees things in in our Western World
try to
feed on on your emotions on your on your
thoughts and everything and I think it's
it's a beautiful transition from
being a jahil like Angel always say
then becoming
so much of
and
a person or a Believer with so much nude
in their faces and I see this in all of
your faces alhamdulillah
may Allah bless you all of you okay all
right so the second question
is what prevented you as born Muslims
from practicing Islam properly in the
past
so go first
for me
the biggest thing that prevented me from
practicing Islam because we only
practice something that we fully believe
in right I'm talking with every fiber of
our being so what prevented me
personally is not knowing that Islam is
the religion but just believing it was a
religion you know just thinking that oh
we don't eat pork and we only eat Halal
and we don't drink and all this because
we're Muslim not because this is the
true religion and this is the only true
religion right I I know that sounds a
little narcissistic to a lot of
non-muslims but so be it and uh that's
why we actually don't do what we do
right because that big Paradigm Shift
between a religion to the true religion
that all of the prophets before us may
peace be upon all of them
um had tried to bring right so that that
paradigm shift is what finally led me as
a born Muslim to just have that Iman
just like any other Muslim whether it be
a river or born Muslim
I guess I'll go next inshallah so I
spent a lot I think it was a combination
of repeatings and I think that the first
one is I think they're both very similar
for everyone uh the first one is a lack
of Islamic knowledge as a kid uh not
everyone's you know fathers
you know not everyone has that that
person like no two not everyone's raised
in the massage it unfortunately and I
was one of those kids like like I said
my parents
I didn't know anything about the prophet
Allah that he was called The Prophet
Muhammad that's all I knew I didn't even
know we were supposed to say salallahu
after he say his name so
um growing up with that little knowledge
and by the way something I want to share
is Iman
linguistically means acceptance of a
fact Iman is not Faith oh I believe in
it Iman is I accept it as a fact one
plus one equals two I have Amen in that
I accept that as a fact Allah is the one
God where they worship I have amen men
in that because I accept that as a fact
I didn't I didn't have Iman and many of
these things I didn't know them how do I
accept them as facts if I don't know
that they're true right so I didn't have
a man and much of anything to be honest
and then growing up in a society where
you know we're being pushed to talk to
girls and we're being pushed to to go
out with them and to do this and that
and then to chat about it and talk about
it and share what we did this and we did
that it's like it's very very corrupting
uh and it's it's very intoxicating
really and then
uh
yeah like I said once I started learning
about Islam everything changed my
perspective changed and uh you change
someone's heart you change your life
basically and that's what happened to me
alhamdulillah illum first illum first
when you get the illum then you can get
Iman then you can get and everything
else will fall into place alhamdulillah
so beautiful so angel I'm sorry this
question is a little bit
Muslim but I could definitely say like
what prevented me and probably was
preventing a lot of non-muslims
from practicing Islam from an early age
or even looking into it or even thinking
about it
right
Bismillah the first thing is that
in my family my mom and my dad got
divorced when I was very young
now because of that I didn't really have
destruction nor that that masculine like
discipline type role model that should
have been there from the rip so that's
number one and uh number two ties in
with number one being that if there is a
strong masculine model
who is leading the household leading the
family
he's going to be Muslim
just think about it like a proper Muslim
is the leader of the household you put a
a far someone who doesn't believe but
now Muslim and a proper Muslim you put
him in the household nine times out of
ten the the non-believer they're just
gonna be
kind of like they don't really care
very feminized and that's just the way
it is in today's society you get the
Muslim man the problem musliment he's
not going to be feminized he's going to
be masculine he's going to be on top of
it he's going to be having structure for
everyone else to follow and adhere to
that gives them the best possible
outcome I didn't have that so I was kind
of lost looking all around and then on
top of that because I was lost looking
all around
I'm going into a society here in the
west like Rami was saying like you get
fed things that are completely against
Islam
like I was under the impression when I
found out about Islam that it was
something wrong by terrorists I think
the first time that I found about Islam
was uh 9 11. I think I was
in maybe like second or third grade
maybe even first grade I don't know I
was in the cafeteria and like we saw
everything on the the TV and then you
know come home my mom's talking about it
with the friends and stuff and then
she's like trying to tell me what it is
like what's going on but it's like look
how
just look how altered all that was and
then I grew up kind of like learning
that and having these misconceptions and
preconceived notions that kept me away
from Islam but again you know without
getting too funny detail I think those
are the uh two biggest things that kept
me and probably keeps a lot of
non-muslims from practicing or going
into Islam
I really appreciate this point of view
it's it's
it's a blessing to hear
that story all right
my brothers
what would you have wished for as
teenagers to get a better understanding
of Islam or to be brought closer to it
Rami is smiling I think he's gonna get
first
I uh exactly what Angel said that that
strong proper masculine figure wrote
having a a good male role model who
knows Islam who could you know teach you
Islam properly
I wish I I had that honestly over
everything else
what about you fired
I'm gonna say something a little
different I don't wish for anything
different at all because I believe that
everything happened exactly the way it
was supposed to happen for me and I
think that because the color of Allah is
so precise if anything had been a little
altered even like fine-tuned a little
differently I may not have ended up on
Dean and uh doing my best to spread
Islam alhamdulillah I might have uh done
something else because you know earlier
in my life Islam was you know introduced
to me but I didn't really Vibe with it
there were times in my life when there
was no Islam but I also didn't go too
into jahilia right so I think everything
happened perfectly the way it was
I might have to agree with both of them
all right so I agree with Rami in what I
said prior to where it's like you know
having that masculine role model I feel
like everyone needs that every man needs
that 100 but a woman also needs that
masculine figure in her life to
understand what the masculine really is
versus maybe just some idea that she has
in her head that's being fed to her by
the media but um I'm gonna agree with
fire and saying that it was all perfect
because if I go back in time
and I really think about this I really
think about the state of being that I
was in like I'm a very disagreeable
person
you guys fired you guys want me like and
this is this is a guy I'm better with
time alhamdulillah but back in my
jahelia like
I was very very disagreeable and even if
I had that masculine role model I don't
know if
if I would have been in the position to
uh submit and actually listen to what
this person was saying let alone submit
to the Creator
you know it's
so alhamdulillah I'm agree with both I'm
agree with both subhanallah
you can see that we got all similarities
in this in this era of of Our Lives that
we all are thankful for what has been
done to us even if it's bad or positive
because everything that we get
we have to say alhamdulillah because
we'll never
will never be that person right now if
we didn't go through that and that and
that poison you know and alhamdulillah
everything so
oh this is such a blessing
so
let's come to the fourth question
what or who do you recommend to those
interested in Islam to consume in order
to avoid common doubts and
misunderstandings in Islam
I think fire should go first this time
I would I would give them a two-step
approach number one go further into the
doubts really learn about the doubt see
where they're coming from right so if
you if you read something that you know
it kind of gives you that about Islam
okay then don't be like oh what if this
leads me away from Islam No go into it I
challenge you go into it there's there's
some refutation out there or there's
someone that exposes you know how these
things were misinterpreted or how these
things were taken out of context and it
won't be long inshallah before you come
into it but if you do want to come into
it this is going to take step number two
which is do this whole process without
ego because if you do this whole process
with the ego then you know you're not
going to want to accept the truth even
if it's handed to you right Allah says
in the Quran that it's as if the
Believers are dumb deaf and blind right
so that's essentially how I feel or how
I felt in in the past when I was
researching things and I was like oh
what if I go more into this but then it
ends me out there's a disbeliever but
it's almost getting over that fear of of
fully yielding and I guess submitting to
Allah that brings you closer
yeah you're totally right
you're totally right
so where's Angel going
I think he's fixing to fix the the cafe
this thing down fell off
mashallah Masha Allah all right thank
you very much
all right
there we go it looks better than before
me
all right it's about a lot um
I I think when it comes to Dustin Islam
like listen
if if Islam is true
like nothing else matters right if
you're doubting something logically and
you look into it in Islam it's gonna
make sense if you're doubting something
emotionally and you look into it
I don't know how you're gonna end up
feeling but feelings are inconsequential
when it comes to the truth right people
don't like the truth of reality people
they're people non-muslims hate that
Islam is true right even abujah
they ask them do you do you believe that
he's a prophecy of course I believe is a
prophet but he's from a different tribe
I'm gonna say that tribe is a prophet
what are we going to have we have
nothing left we we submit to them
basically he didn't want to do that he
hated it who cares who cares how he
feels and and the same thing with Abu
lahab what Allah says is going to be in
the fire he says that in the Quran he's
going to be punished for it it's about
Allah so
if it's emotional it doesn't really
matter I hate to say it it doesn't
matter if it's logical then just go deal
with it literally go to the local mosque
and ask the Sheikh and if you can't if
there's no one nearby you can't find
people nearby then find people online
people uh you know with with generally
big followings you know the the UK that
is and and and uh dies online like even
even us like you could reach out to us
shoot us a message say hey I heard about
it says beat your wives in Islam what
does that mean and then we'll explain
that it doesn't literally mean to beat
up your wife stuff in a lot of them
that's actually punishable Instagram
um and and many things like that so it's
if it's logical just go ask a Muslim and
if they don't know then you're pushing a
Muslim to go seek knowledge and if
anything that's better I just want to
quickly add something before brother
is saying that essentially Vibes with
what I was saying too because my first
point of going deeper into it and
learning it that's essentially what he
was saying about logical doubt
or logical skepticism and then the
second point which is me saying strip
away or ego and identity that's the
emotional skepticism part of it
alhamdulillah
very good friend could you repeat the
question
of course Angela of course
what or who do you recommend to those
interested in Islam to consume in order
to avoid
um common doubts and misunderstandings
in Islam
proper Quran translation
you know because
again we'll fight and say well Romney
said it's all beautiful
but we need like that proper Quran
translation in whatever language that
this person is gonna best receive it in
you know it's like I started off with uh
very old English
type of Quran alhamdulillah like it
still brought me to Islam but it's not
until I picked up the clerical end which
is recommended by Brother Rami just like
about here that one once I started
reading it I was like Masha Allah like
the way that it's broken down and just
all the points and it's just the
clarification on it allows me to truly
understand the Quran
in way more depth and detail than I did
when I was reading the old English one
and again alhamdulillah like if you're
gonna be got it you're going to be
guided but you need a clear translation
to kind of like grasp the true
understanding of it at least the closest
thing possible before starting to learn
the classical Arabic and then
understanding the Quran to that that
specific tone you know what I mean
but very important when fire said you
know you you got to come to with an
empty cup you gotta remove everything
that you have and really ask the
questions like why why do you have that
skepticism whether it be emotional
logical and then like Rami said you
gotta
I said I forgot what Romney said but I
definitely did agree with you I know
that's for sure I just forgot
I think he just said almost the same
um just putting away your emotional
stuff and I think women specifically
have a problem with that uh just a
little quick reminder for all women out
there it's
sometimes it's pretty hard to be a woman
these days but if you just
try to get into your masculine energy
and try to be rational about things then
you can get the truth out of Islam and
and realize that this is the only way of
dealing with this Dunya and in order to
get to Jannah inshallah
and pause before we continue I actually
like what you said there because
if the woman doesn't have the strong
masculine figure in her life that can
guide her in this direction
right then that's when she kind of needs
to take it upon herself for that brief
period of time to really just exercise
her masculine ability and like take her
emotions out of the equation because
listen emotions are great but it's very
it's very hard to uh grasp and
understand things when you're coming
from an emotional perspective and that
goes for men and women you know
that's facts yeah that's funny though
just to add to that quickly the prophet
Allah there is a Hadith I think in the
Muslim Ahmed he said that the um the the
heart the the emotions the heart of a
person is like a feather at the root of
a tree being turned over and over by the
wind
so if you're a motion is something
you're going off of your nuts your heart
it's something you're going off of it's
going to constantly be turning over and
over it's upon Allah just want to add
that quickly
beautiful Hadith
so Brothers we come to the last question
how do I get an Islamic lifestyle in
these times of massive fitna
um I would say yeah go on bro
all right I'm gonna keep it short and
sweet I would say if you can't
you know I was thinking of a quote but
uh forget that I'll just go right into
it change your surroundings people
because if you change your surroundings
if you if you can't change what you're
seeing
um which is around you which is just you
know fitna and this and that and people
that are just straying you away from
Islam change the people in your
surroundings so what you see will change
as well right so this could be uh very
difficult if it's family right but uh
you know if your family genuinely isn't
you know pushing you towards Islam or
they're they're themselves in an
ignorant stage right then I guess you
can move out try to live by yourself
something like that go uh to the
massages you know surround yourself with
a lot of different people that are on
Dean
um people that are on the correct team
and all that uh get new friends change
your friends change your circle and over
time it'll become much easier inshallah
100 I agree wholeheartedly I want to add
a little bit it's kind of lost so the uh
I think people really do underestimate
the their surroundings right there's a
quote
um show me your friends I'll show you
your future or something like that and
it's very truthful in life the process I
said he said there's a Hadith where he
speaks about a man who who's near like a
blacksmith all the time how he's always
going to smell like smoke and a man who
is near like um uh like a perfume shop
is he gonna smell really nice all the
time
um and that's basically your
surroundings your friends right what you
see and what you do and what you think
and what you say they're all like they
all work like in a triangle right
um thoughts feelings and actions all
work in a triangle and um what you see
influences all those things so if you
can change what you're inputting to your
brain you're going to change what you're
going to be outputting uh in your life
so I want to second that 100 also I want
to say that people have to know it's an
uphill battle we're living in the west
we're not living under Sharia law we're
not living in an Islamic State there's
no
lot of sometimes there aren't there's
not even a muscular bias it is an uphill
battle so take it one step at a time and
and start with knowledge learn about
Islam learn about what needs to be
changed and then take the steps to
change that focus on what's flooded
first right your five daily prayers
and do what you can or do what you need
to First Once you have that down then
slowly add on over time and over time it
will become easier but don't don't throw
it all on yourself at once because
you know what it's like putting you know
50 pounds on your head going uphill
you're going to Tumble backwards and
that's not something we want
hmm and it's like Allah says in the
Quran like do the Believers think
that they'll say that they believe and
not be tested
you know so to tie off the point because
I feel like all three of us have the
same view here so the title Love
if I had said change your environment
right the Romney adds on uh the friends
the people you surround yourself with
and you said the beautiful Hadith
where it's like if you have a blacksmith
as a friend you're probably gonna smell
like smoke even if you don't even engage
in what he's doing if you have a a
friend who sells perfume you're gonna
smell amazing even if you don't touch
the perfumes just by being around them
right but then it's also I I think this
is a Hadith as well so correct me if I'm
wrong but uh
I believe the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam said that
it's better to be alone
than in Bad Company
but it's better to be with good company
than to be alone so yes we need to
change our environment we need to have
better company around us but if we can't
do that right now then the best change
that we can do is to spend more time by
ourselves and with the Creator Allah and
then from there as we spend more time
with ourselves and the Creator and we
raise ourselves in our Iman and our
intellect understanding and just improve
overall as beings we start to attract
other people that are also on that same
wave that same frequency
and then then once you attract those
people well now it's better to spend
time with them than to be alone because
when you spend time with them you're
only raising
in uh in more ways than you could think
possible versus if you were to remain
alone
subhanallah oh
it has been such a rational of Allah
that he has made this interview possible
alhamdulillah
allow us to become righteous servants
with the best
while inspiring anyone to do better
may he allow us to become students of
knowledge striving for agenda being
beneficial to our ummah may Allah
blesses all our families especially our
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam his
family and companions
thank you for sharing your story with
all of us today
follow the three Muslims and even
for more Islamic content inshallah
brother Ami are you ready
I am indeed with that being said
what are you doing well it's in my head
man like I think there's another thing
too it's it's the perseverance aspect
too like we're more willing to stick
through with things that we set out with
an intention it's impossible to have
empathy for others if you're not patient
so my love bless you for that first
album I agree with the fact that the
whole thing you said about friends where
it's like if they're affecting you more
than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends you
want to be investing you know stocks
shares bonds you want to be investing in
crypto because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is Haram at least
the paper money is hold on provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic Hamza Andreas we will go in with
our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little Clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin so you
don't want to be on YouTube or the
internet or anything that that amount of
time but it's it's the the fact is
that's what we're doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]